[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and with bond showing up at the
end of chapter 300 seemingly to save the
day I feel like it's the perfect time
right now to make a video about him and
how powerful he is right now
before we get into that I've been
wanting to make a video about both Eska
Noir and zelgius recently so I decided
to make a poll on Instagram where you
guys can vote for which video you want
to see first follow our instagram at
anime uproar I'll link it in the
description then just click on the story
and vote for which video you want to see
first we will have future video polls
like this on Instagram so make sure
you're following us so you can vote on
those two like and subscribe if you want
to see more 7 Deadly Sins content on
this channel and let me know what kind
of videos you'd like to see in the
future in the comment section below a
final warning there will be many manga
spoilers in this video all the way up to
chapter 300 so you've been warned now
let's start talking about bonds power
for a long time he was known for his
immortality but besides that he wasn't
that strong his ability snatch as the
name suggests allows him to snatch
things from the enemy
this can include body parts like their
hearts or their power - he can become
stronger and faster while his opponents
become weaker and slower however the
issue with disability is that there's a
limit to the amount of power bond can
steal from someone his body is not
strong enough to handle overwhelming
power he is able to overpower a pree
demon mark meliodas in chapter 36 thanks
to this ability but Mele Otis with the
demon mark on his forehead was able to
completely wreck even this peridot bond
even after he only stole some of
melioidosis power afterwards he says
they using physical hunt makes his body
feel wicked heavy and he wants to sleep
so even though he's immortal there are
limits to how much power he can absorb
and how long he can keep it for before
feeling the after effects overall bond
doesn't have a great track record for
strength before he became immortal he
fought a red demon they only have a
power level between 1000 1003
yet he was mortally wounded along with
Elaine bond was only saved from the
injury because Elaine made him drink the
Fountain of Youth water which he had
told her to drink after this he was
immortal and able to beat the red demon
but because he was not strong enough at
first
Elaine got injured and died in his place
he can defeat Jericho and Jude without
much trouble after he decides to leave
prison but a demon blood and enhanced
Jericho takes him out later during his
fight with Galan after he steals a
significant amount of gallons physical
power molasse Gila suggests that his
combat class might even be higher than
gallons at that point but she points out
his weakness she asks him why doesn't he
take all of galas power then she tells
him it's because he can't it's a problem
with his body's tolerance level as I
previously mentioned
despite being immortal his body still
has a tolerance level that limits his
ability to use snatch after he manages
to use Stach to run away from gallon in
mille ask allah the consequences for
using snatch hit him so hard that he
says he isn't even able to lift a single
finger as a result gallon strength is
about 27,000 in total not counting his
overdrive mode 24,000 of it is his
physical strength
thus we can assume that bond lowered
gallons power by over half and increased
his own base power of 3220 by the same
amount let's say he borrowed 14,000
combat class points from Galan making
his own temporarily around 17,000 this
figure is around where his limit is at
this point and not only that he can't
maintain it for long and suffers
debilitating consequences after using it
he has to be saved by esken or who after
the Sun comes up effortlessly defeats
gallant and moleska from this point on
bond cannot keep up in terms of strength
with Eska nor and the costly powering up
captain bond is one of my favorite
characters but for a long time it is
made blatantly clear that he lacks
strength when Mele Otis is being killed
by the 10 commandments bond takes
mulaskey law by surprise breaks her neck
and steals multiple hearts from her he
doesn't end up killing her for good but
he takes her out of commission for the
rest of that fight but this only leads
to one of the most tragic parts of the
manga where bond has to
watch as esther osa kills his best
friend in front of his eyes
bond uses his full strength he takes the
snatch ability to the limit and he is
completely powerless to stop Esther Rosa
from killing Mellie Otis bond thinks to
himself and I quote I can't protect my
woman or my one friend in the world
tears stream down his face as Esther OSA
takes out melioidosis final heart
without even moving
Esther OSA is able to completely destroy
bonds body bond is immortal so he
survives but at this point he has hit
rock bottom as a man he has not been
able to protect his woman or his best
friend all he was to Esther osa was an
annoyance not only his bonds
powerlessness emphasized so is the fact
that he strongly feels his own
powerlessness later
ESCA nor be testa Rossa the man bond
couldn't even scratch we see Mellie
Otis's assault mode we CSKA NORs the one
mode we see Kings new form and so on
bond for the longest time could not keep
up not even close
however that's all changed with his
decision to go into purgatory and rescue
Mellie Otis's emotions
Merlin tells us that apart from the
curse captain she only knows of one
other person who went to purgatory and
made it back alive
that was her father a powerful man the
elder sage and chief of the capital he
was there for just one minute and that
one minute according to Merlin reduced
him to an invalid we find out that the
air in purgatory is mixed with the most
scorching heat and blistering unbearable
cold and the earth is deathly toxic it
destroys the flesh of the living space
time itself is warped there so that the
passing of one minute could change into
that of a year it even includes
predatory monsters seeking their prey
Merlin believes that is impossible for
anyone to do it however in chapter 243
almost 70 chapters after bought
helplessly watched his best friend get
killed in front of his eyes
he sees his opportunity for redemption
since he is immortal he is the only one
with a chance of getting melioidosis
emotions back from purgatory they don't
want to let him go because it is too
dangerous but bond begs them and I quote
please let me do this I want to save my
best friend with my own hands if I can't
do that then there's no way I could
protect the woman I'm head-over-heels
for can I
and so with that it's agreed that bond
will go when we see bond in purgatory we
see him reverting back to his human form
he had almost lost his mind wandering
for so long his beard is extremely long
and he questions how many centuries he's
been in purgatory his skin is burning
and he's coughing up blood luckily he's
immortal so he does heal even while his
flesh is being destroyed constantly in
purgatory after enduring such costs and
torture in purgatory for centuries bond
eventually finds Mele Otis's emotions at
first Mele Otis has taken the form of a
purgatory monster bond fights him for
decades long enough for his burned off
beard to grow quite long again bond
tells Mele Otis that for the first
hundred years he revived from being
burned to ashes from freezing to the
bone from rotting from deadly poison you
name it and it just kept on repeating
but he says after the last 200 years
he's gotten used to the harsh conditions
of purgatory like the indigenous animals
whose bodies have evolved to withstand
purgatory
he's even able to sleep in purgatory now
later bond gets good enough to easily
defeat monsters from purgatory that gave
him trouble before Mele Otis is amazed
at his ability to adapt to the harsh
conditions bond gets to the point where
his body is completely unaffected by
burns or frostbite in his lungs which
used to be swollen can now breathe in
purgatory like it was fresh air Mele
Otis says he may be the only human who
will ever spend over a thousand years in
purgatory managed to survive and also
hang on to his sanity belly Otis points
out that bonds experience of enduring
and adapting to purgatory has caused an
explosive transformation upon his body
and soul he ensures him that everyone
will be shocked when they see how much
he's powered up then eventually Mele
Otis and bond come face to face with the
demon king in purgatory they actually
thought him 6090 three times in the span
of 60 years and lost each time they
fight the demon king again and they lose
again and Hawkes brother wild gets hurt
this is when bond realizes that he can
heal people by giving his energy to them
he explains that for the last 60 years
every single time he tried to steal the
demon Kings power or stamina his own
ended up getting absorbed
so because of this his body which could
always steal energy learned how to give
energy that's when Mele oldest figures
out that the demon King's original power
is to reverse everything so he gains
energy when bond tries to steal it
as a result next time they fight bond
tries giving him energy and this brings
the demon king to his knees the demon
king can turn his inversion ability off
so bond is not able to simply beat him
by using reverse thatch however he did
get the demon king to turn off his
ability so that malleolus his emotions
could use his original power to destroy
the demon King's arm and escape from
purgatory
but then at the end of chapter 292 bond
comes back to the real world and we are
told that with the strength he gained in
purgatory the time to give hope has come
clearly the story is making a really big
deal out of the powers he's gained from
purgatory in the next chapter bond goes
to see Elaine who is fighting demons
along with Matrona and others they are
struggling but bond shows up and with
one movement of his arm he takes out all
of the demons around him and Elaine
taking out so many demons some of who
are copper demons and have a combat
class as high as 4,500 shows how far
bond has come in the past bond wasn't
strong enough to even protect the lane
from one red demon who only go up to a
combat class of 1300 now he's able to
take out countless stronger demons
effortlessly then Vaughan goes on to
fully redeem himself for the failure to
save Elaine so many years ago with his
new ability to give life energy he is
able to exchange his immortality for
Elaine's full revival now that he
fulfilled his promise to Elaine what's
left is for him to go help Mele ODIs in
the last chapter we find out that the
demon king is using Mele Otis's body as
a vessel his power is so great that King
in his new form mile Merlin and the
others are unable to even phase him in
the official translation Merlin tells
King and the N and I quote don't assume
that attack magic will work on the demon
lord as we learned in purgatory the
demon Kings power allows him to turn any
attack against him into healing and
fortification all hope seems lost and
the demon king is about to kill hawk
when bond uses some insane speed to save
him this
is the first time we've seen the demon
king surprised by anyone's abilities
since he's entered Mele Otis's body
despite how strong bond knows the demon
king is remember that he has fought him
more times than anyone present when he
was in purgatory he nonetheless his
confidence says can you hear me captain
let's kick this deadbeat dad of yours
out of here already
bond is not worried or sweating like the
other characters he's acting like he can
take on the demon king is he right
we know he's gotten stronger but how
strong has he gotten it is true that
bond is no longer mortal but he is also
stronger than ever and I'll explain why
if we recall you'll remember that his
biggest issue was his human body's
tolerance level his snatch ability is
insanely good
but he was limited by his body but as
Mele Otis's emotions point out bond
spent over a thousand years in purgatory
and his body after being broken down so
many times in so many different ways
evolved to the point where it was
unaffected by the harsh conditions
purgatory for bond was like a super
extreme hyperbolic time chamber instead
of ten times Earth's gravity denser air
and some temperature fluctuations Balan
has to deal with poison air burning and
freezing conditions that would kill a
mortal and with the very strong and fast
monsters of purgatory this experience
inevitably led to what Mele owed is
called bonds explosive body and soul
transformation his one weakness
his body's low tolerance level is no
longer an issue after all that time
spent in purgatory and training under
such harsh conditions bonds body must
have one of the highest tolerance levels
in the entire world of the seven deadly
sins
this unimaginably high tolerance level
is now going to allow him to use smash
to absorb massive amounts of power from
those around him he already has a much
stronger base power after purgatory but
now he's also going to be able to
increase it exponentially with snatch
with disability I believe that he can
now easily surpass King mile and the
rest although I'm not counting mile in
one mode because noone has passed and we
don't even know if the fight is gonna
last long enough so that mile would be
able to use it the fact is that bond is
the only one that has a shot to defeat
the demon king right now he has the most
experience fighting him he
undergone a massive power boost to the
point where even the demon king is
surprised by his speed he's gonna be
able to absorb an insane amount of power
from his friends and possibly even from
the demon king himself and if the demon
king has his inversion ability activated
bond can still hurt him by attempting to
transfer his own power to the demon king
I believe that these are the reasons
that bomb is calm right now with snatch
and his evolved body I believe he has
the ability to surpass all of his allies
and strength he's come a long way from
being one of the weakest members of the
seven deadly sins and I cannot be more
excited about that he used to hate his
own powerlessness but now it would seem
that he finally has the power to keep
his promises to both his woman and his
best friend the million dollar question
is is bond going to be able to beat the
demon king in a one-on-one fight we'll
have to wait and see but I at the very
least think that he'll be able to weaken
the demon king enough so that Mele
Otis's emotions which are supposed to be
out of purgatory and back in his body by
now will be able to take back control
if bond lowers the demon Kings power
enough it is possible that Mele Otis as
bond suggests will be able to kick the
demon king out of his body then we might
see Mele Otis himself clash against his
father a battle that I think will have
to happen at some point but anyways
those are my thoughts on how strong I
think bond is I'm so happy that he was
able to become stronger and finally
overcome that feeling of powerlessness
thank you so much for watching if you
liked this video and want to see more
like it make sure to smash that like
button if you haven't make sure to
subscribe for more seven deadly sins
videos don't forget to vote on instagram
at anime uproar for what video you would
like to see and remember that fans of
the channel can get 25% off our anime
inspired shirts including shirts like
meliodas feel the wrath and esken or
praise the sun just go to anime AFRICOM
link in the description and use the code
uproar 25 at checkout thank you for all
of your support and until next time see
ya space cowboy
[Music]
you
[Music]